Johnna me now is the anti brexit
campaigner Jean and Miller
she has launched a fresh legal action to
try to stop Boris Johnson suspending
Parliament welcome to you in a sense
isn't all of this partly your fault in
as much as you used extra parliamentary
means to try and stop breaks it when you
went to the Supreme Court you won but
now mr. Johnson is trying to get his way
again by using unusual means so my court
case back in three years ago was not to
stop brexit did never did that very
intent no it was not it with the intent
was to give Parliament his voice and for
MPs to vote on article 50 which is
exactly what they did because if the
Prime Minister at that time and the
Prime Minister again is allowed to use
their powers in an illegal manner that
sets a precedent because we don't have a
written constitution we don't have a
written constitution but there are those
people who would say that the people
spoke in the referendum and what your
legal challenge did means that now MPs
have the final say rather than the
people and you knew perfectly well when
he launched it then the majority of MPs
were actually thought breaks it was a
bad idea so if we could not rewrite
history the EM the referendum was
advisory and then that was voted on by
the MPs who voted it but immediately
been saying me is saying me a referendum
was advisory is again a technicality
because because the prime minister of
the time said it would be binding its
but the law maintenant unjust I
understand the norm at it but all I'm
saying is it's what we've got now is
this kind of constitutional Mexican
standoff between various people using
various mechanisms to try and get their
way and the it is your party to that no
absolutely not because this is about the
law and it does matter because we don't
have that written constitution and
precedents are then set what it then
means is that any Prime Minister in the
future could decide if they don't like
what's going on in Parliament that they
could use their power and program
prorogue Parliament shut it down for a
length of time I mean five weeks out
they're proposing is the longest we've
seen in modern history that's one week
strode than what was being proposed
anywhere
season well it's not quite that
straightforward because next week what
happens is MPs votes are on recess so
just before so a lot of MPs have been
talking about perhaps not rising for
conference season because it's such a
crucial time or maybe sitting a couple
of days a week that's that's breaking
with president because MPs normally do
rise for the party conference season but
they've also sucked when it is times of
national emergencies they've even sat on
Saturdays as they did during the
Falklands War what that is for one day
but the fact is until we change what we
are we are a representative democracy
until that changes then Parliament
cannot be shut down by a change when
there was a referendum that's the point
oh did we change our democracy I didn't
think we did I thought what because
that's not the normal way we do business
but we decided we're going to have a
referendum the Prime Minister day said
it would be binding and MP's followed
that through they triggered article 50
there then also voted for the role act
in 2018 so MPs have been going all the
way through this what's your new
challenge about that the new challenge
is to say that you know however you look
at this it's not the act of using the
product of power to perot Parliament
that we believe is illegal it's the
effects of using it in a manner that the
intention is to bypass Parliament or the
effect is to limit their voice and they
are our representatives and Parliament
has expressed three times so far that
they're against nobody's it's all about
no do it again to a certain extent
you've been outfoxed by Downing Street
on this because when Jacob Riis mark
says it's perfectly normal to have a
fresh session of Parliament it is
particularly when to other factors are
relevant one is we've had a change of
Prime Minister and two as you know we've
had an abnormally long session they're
stretching to two and a half years which
most people who I'm not this isn't isn't
there a need anyway to refresh the
parliamentary of the direction of the
government through a Queen's Speech it
nobody's disputing that we are not
disputing that I mean other people I can
only speak to myself and my legal team
we're not disputing disputing that what
we're saying is that this abnormal time
of five weeks will have the effect of
limiting
ability to pass legislation against No
Deal which is what Parliament has
expressed and a growing number of MPs
are expressing that they wish to do to
actually ensure that No Deal doesn't
damage our country this is not about
leaving this is about No Deal yeah but
again the stated position of the
government as we heard yesterday and the
letter to MPs from Boris Johnson is that
his intention is not to get No Deal he
wishes to get a deal and he has created
time or the government has created time
within the parliamentary agenda for MPS
to approve that deal or not to approve
it and have no deal with it with within
within the parliamentary timetable so
that so MPs aren't being denied to say
that is actually not true if you look at
the actions of what they're proposing
because the timetable is such is that it
will hamper MPs if you look at the
cupola qín amendment that took five days
this they will have five they will only
have four days because there are
ceremonies and debates that go around a
degree in speech there are many
different but what you're trying to do
is to facilitate something which again
is pretty clear normal which is non
governmental forces taking control of
the parliamentary timetable I'm saying
that the meaningful vote that you are
secured in the Supreme Court can take
place there is time within the
parliamentary term table before at the
end of October for that to take place
well they're a growing number of MPs and
there are lawyers and different people
different opinion who actually don't
believe that's true they think that
there won't be enough time to bring in
legislation if that's what mp's choose
to do but that's different from a
meaningful vote could be operative in
this case as far as approving indies we
can tell MPs what it is they wish to do
they just need to have the time to be
able to explore all the options because
until we have a different sort of system
we are a parliamentary democracy
remember remember sovereignty is the
thing that everyone having Donna had the
government down what domini Rob was
talking about during Lygia campaign and
Pro Road so there'd be no chance for
Parliament to consider what happens that
would have been much worse
I think everyone whatever
everyone agrees that would always
service in a constitution but in this
case there is actually that two-week
period and the MPs can if there is a
fresh offer from the European Union they
could approve that rather than lot for
no deal can they oh I think that this is
all very clever I'm not I'm not
disputing that what the government have
done it's very clever and mr. Johnson
his advisors but that is not the point
the point is that using this power this
pora Gatien that they have to close down
pylons and limit the time it has to do
what it wants because it may wish to do
other things other than debates No Deal
or to support and withdrawal agreement I
mean the withdrawal agreement itself
took over six hundred and sixty five
days empties could have voted not to go
a whole day over the summer they didn't
well they didn't have the opportunity to
do that and they didn't have that at the
moment the Prime Minister is actually
say demanding that they actually rise
for five weeks and that we believe is
illegal and unconstitutional and because
there are very many different opinions
that is why we would seek a judicial
review there's no guarantee of course
that we will all be accepted we're just
approaching the collateral what do you
think the timetable would be for that
well it's a very urgent one we've lodged
yesterday I didn't want to lodge I mean
this is a whole ridiculous thing I don't
want to be in this position because over
the summer we have had numerous letters
from the government the last at five
o'clock on Monday saying under no
circumstances were they provoked and
that we didn't have to go to court and
it was a academic so they've actually
been saying that all over summer and
then you know they're out there sending
us that letter at five o'clock on Monday
whilst they're drafting their press
release on propagation you know it
doesn't look as the acts of a government
that's being very straight on anything
actually at the moment so when it comes
back to the timetable we've approached
the course we lodged yesterday we've see
we're seeking to be heard next week
because of the 9th of September deadline
and we'll have to wait to see if that
happens if it doesn't then we don't have
permission and there's no case and bear
in mind some of the hard line things
that have been said for a number-10 even
if you were to win are you sure that
would be enough to bring the government
to heel it's not about prison bringing
the governor to you want the government
to do something it doesn't want to do
but it's about the government however
clever they're being is doing something
that's not
illegal and that's what we will be
asking the course is this legal the
advice has been given to the Queen has a
prime minister overstepped his the
powers that he has and you believe it is
illegal we are my legal team and I feel
that the effect of using this power is
to shut their own Parliament and to
limit their voice and that would be
illegal because it is a sovereign
Parliament